just say it she's your student you're
happy you're 12. let's just admit it
uh you did a good job for your teacher
today
were you surprised at the kind of move
she made she made some moves that were
just bishop takes on c6 instead of
knight takes or knight back to c8
instead of 194 it looked like she was
just backing all her pieces up and gave
you a really fine chance to win the game
yeah i was surprised i don't know why
she actually picked that moose at least
knight c4 rook c8 like she needs to try
something after knight c8 it's just my
play
that's why
it was surprising and after uh i took on
c6 knight c6 is the only move for her
like
she's holding a position and it should
be just playable for black
you were
in a tie for eighth place before the
beginning of the day all of a sudden
you're tied for second place
that's a pretty remarkable lead uh it
doesn't mean anything yet we have six
more rounds so it doesn't matter
has your coach been giving you great
advice i'm just putting you on the spot
yes sir sorry
sorry i just something tickled
we both just doing our job i think as
best as we can so
i'm going to leave it at that because i
know he's smiling from here to here by
the way i will let you know we had
predictor move today we have a new
segment yeah an in-game prediction not a
move but a prediction about the results
and uh
i said you were going to lose the game
oh thank you yeah i appreciate your
support
yes sir and and
um and var says you were going to win
the game yeah and your coach said you
were only going to draw the game
interesting
silence
i'm going to be happy if she draws and
i'm going to be happy if she knows such
a good support in this tournament
tournament it's just incredible
i thought you were terrific i appreciate
your support you're the best
i knew that thank you you're terrific
coach we're going to talk later
well fine win today congratulations and
good luck the rest of the way thank you
very much well done well done